En este video veremos cuatro formas distintas
de calcular el área de un triángulo a partir de
la información que tengamos, así que comencemos.
Aquí tenemos tres triángulos. ¿Puedes determinar
qué es lo que tienen en común? Pausa el video y
piénsalo. Hay algo interesante que tienen en común
estos tres triángulos, y puede no ser evidente.
Resulta que los tres tienen la misma área. ¿Cómo
podemos comprobar esto? Bueno, una de las formas
de encontrar el área de un triángulo es utilizar
la fórmula que dice que hay que multiplicar su
base por su altura y dividirlo entre 2. Cada
uno de los triángulos de nuestro ejemplo tiene una
longitud de base de 5 centímetros y una altura de
8 centímetros, al multiplicar 5 cm por 8 cm nos da
40 cm². Después, si dividimos esa cantidad entre
2, obtendremos el área. Entonces, el área de cada
triángulo es de 20 cm². Tenemos tres triángulos
distintos con la misma área. Estoy seguro de que
reconoces esta forma de calcular el área de un
triángulo, ya que es la forma tradicional que
se enseña en la educación básica. Ahora, ¿qué
pasará si no conocemos la altura del triángulo?
Bueno, veamos la siguiente forma de calcular su
área. Esta vez vamos a encontrarla con la ayuda
de la Fórmula de Herón usando el semiperímetro,
es decir, la mitad del perímetro. En este
escenario, tenemos un triángulo y sabemos el valor
de todos sus lados, entonces, vamos a definir el
semiperímetro del triángulo como el perímetro,
es decir, la suma de las longitudes de cada
lado del triángulo, esto dividido entre 2,
y llamaremos al semiperímetro S. Entonces, el
semiperímetro de este triángulo es (5 cm) + (8
cm) + (7 cm) / 2, que es 20 cm / 2, lo cual
son 10 cm. Ojo, todavía no tenemos el área,
pero el semiperímetro nos ayudará a obtenerla con
la siguiente expresión: el área es igual a la raíz
cuadrada del semiperímetro por el semiperímetro
menos el primer lado, por el semiperímetro menos
el segundo lado, por el semiperímetro menos el
tercer lado (A = √ S (S-a) (S-b) (S-c)). Ésta es
la fórmula de Herón para encontrar el área de un
triángulo. Así que, bueno, vamos a utilizarla esta
vez. El área va a ser igual a la √ 10 cm (10 cm
- 5 cm) (10 cm - 8 cm) (10 cm - 7 cm); es decir,
esto va a ser lo mismo que: √ 10 cm (5 cm) (2
cm) (3 cm); es decir, la raíz cuadrada de, bueno,
10 • 5 es 50, 50 • 2 es 100, 100 • 3 es 300, 300
cm⁴, o dicho otra manera, esto es lo mismo que:
√ 3 • √ 100 cm⁴. Y es que esto ya se puede
acomodar de la siguiente manera: √ 100 cm⁴, bueno,
eso es 10 cm², y esto por la √ 3, o dicho de otra
manera: 10 √ 3 cm². Ahora bien, si sacamos nuestra
calculadora para obtener un valor aproximado de
esta área: 10 √ 3 es aproximadamente igual a,
si redondeamos a dos cifras significativas,
17.32 cm². Así que, ya sabemos cómo podemos
obtener el área de un triángulo si tenemos sólo
la medida de sus lados: con la Fórmula de Herón y
utilizando el semiperímetro. Siguiendo la misma
idea, ¿cómo podríamos encontrar el área de un
triángulo equilátero? Como sabemos, un triángulo
equilátero es aquel en el que todos sus lados son
iguales y todos sus ángulos son iguales. Aquí
tenemos un triángulo equilátero, sus tres lados
miden lo mismo y nos dicen que cada lado mide
6 centímetros. Si todos los lados son iguales,
entonces estos otros dos lados miden también
6 centímetros, ¿cierto? Bueno, siguiendo la
Fórmula de Herón podemos llegar a esta expresión
que nos sirve para encontrar el área de cualquier
triángulo equilátero sin saber su altura.
Para el caso de los triángulos equiláteros,
la fórmula se simplifica en esta expresión: A = √
3 / 4 (l)². Así que, ¿cuál es el área aproximada
de este triángulo? Inténtalo. Bueno, vamos a
trabajar juntos. El área es igual a la √ 3 / 4,
que multiplica a 6 cm²; esto es lo mismo que la √
3 / 4 (36 cm²), lo cual es, bueno, 36/4 es 9, 9 √
3 cm², o, si sacamos la calculadora, esto es igual
a 9 √ 3 es 15.59 cm², si redondeamos a dos cifras
significativas. Bien, ya sabemos cómo calcular
el área de un triángulo si tenemos la base y
la altura o si tenemos la longitud de todos sus
lados. Ahora vamos a hacer algo distinto, vamos
a ver una situación en donde tenemos otros datos.
¿Qué pasará si sólo nos dan un ángulo y dos lados?
Imagina este caso: conocemos la longitud de dos
lados y el ángulo entre ellos. ¿Cómo encontramos
el área de este triángulo? Bueno, tenemos otra
expresión que nos ayudará a encontrar el área de
una manera sencilla: utilizando trigonometría. En
este caso, el área se encuentra con la siguiente
expresión: área es igual a b, la longitud del lado
b, por c, la longitud del lado c, esto entre 2
por el seno del ángulo alfa (A = b • c / 2 • sen
(α)), es decir, el seno del ángulo que se forma
entre estos dos lados. Así que veamos cuál es el
área de este triángulo en particular. El área va
a ser igual a (12 m) (10 m), esto entre 2, por
el seno del ángulo que forman estos dos lados,
es decir: el sen (30°). Y, bueno, sabemos que el
sen (30°) es 1/2, entonces esto es lo mismo que:
(12 m) (10 m) es 120 m² / 2 por 1/2, lo cual es
120 / 4, que son 30 m². Y seguro te preguntarás
¿qué pasa si no tenemos el ángulo entre estos dos
lados? Bueno, es fácil obtenerlo usando la Ley de
senos o la Ley de cosenos, y en Khan Academy
tenemos muchos videos al respecto, así que te
invito a que los veas, ya que ambas leyes son
muy, muy, muy útiles en trigonometría. Bueno,
pues aquí lo tienes. Hemos visto cuatro formas
distintas de calcular el área de un triángulo,
dependiendo de los datos que tengamos a la mano:
ya sea con la base y la altura o teniendo sólo la
longitud de los lados y, como caso particular,
tenemos el triángulo equilátero, o si tenemos
dos lados y un ángulo, el ángulo que se forma
entre esos dos lados. En otro video hablaremos
de algunas relaciones entre las áreas de regiones
de triángulos. Nos vemos en el próximo video.